au sommaire le piton textor depuis la
plaine des palmistes la curiosité de la
semaine le domaine des tourelles
rendez-vous à la plaine des palmistes
pour village du bras des calumets prend
la direction du piton textor vous
pourrez vous garer sur le parking au
départ du sentier
pour cette randonnée de difficulté
moyenne longue de 6 km prévoir de bonnes
chaussures de quoi vous protéger de la
pluie nous sommes dans les eaux et une
réserve d'eau
pour votre santé parcours et nos
sentiers
sentiers presque jumeau de celui qui
monte au piton de l'eau ce sentier du
piton textor depuis la plaine est un bel
itinéraire qui permet de découvrir des
pentes nord ouest du volcan
à quelques centaines de mètres du départ
un cratère est visible depuis le bord du
sentier le peas armand nommé python
dorée du nom d'un gouverneur qui serait
tombé dedans
cette première partie à l'ombre des
cryptomérias est longue comme toujours
festival des exotiques ce milieu non
permet pas moins de faire de belles
découvertes comme 7,6 l'orchis mais
surtout cette impressionnante citation
d'une autre orchidées qui mérite que
l'on s'y attarde
pas sûr
le monde
montez au piton textor depuis la plaine
des palmistes c'est suivre un sentier
chargé d'histoire c'est celui
qu'emprunte est en effet la majorité des
premiers explorateurs du volcan pour se
rendre jusqu'au pas de bellecombe depuis
saint benoît leur père ils prenaient
plusieurs jours une vraie aventure
pour nous le sentier parfois raide mais
bien tracé et le changement de
végétation liés à l'altitude encourage
nos efforts
là on commence vraiment changé de milieu
tu vois on commence à rentrer dans la
team manthey on a on a la présence déjà
du petit amar et des eaux l'alti monte à
la réunion c'est tout ce qu'on peut
trouver à au dessus de 1800 mètres
d'altitude
c'est là au maître d'autres espèces ont
commencé à apparaître des espèces qui ne
supportent pas forcément la chaleur qui
aime bien ce milieu un peu humide et
froide altitude donc une végétation
assez particulière voilà fait fait dans
ma ville des eaux fait de bond fait de
ce forêt de tamarins aussi des eaux
quand l'antenne apparaît soudain entre
les branches c'est signe que le piton
textor n'est plus très loin les brandes
comme les fleurs jaunes sont de plus en
plus présent même si certains d'entre
eux ont été utilisées pour la chasse aux
adeptes ça mais voilà on a un exemple de
mauvaises pratiques forestières
là c'est ce qu'on appelle la chasse
s'endette maison dette ce sont des
petites larves au plus ou moins grosses
d'insectes en général 2
de scarabées deux types d'armes ton qui
vont pondre dans les arbres c'est un peu
comme les guêpes on va dire ça m'inspire
but 7 à 6 mois je rappelle une époque on
cherchait le monde est dans le bois
pourri au sol maintenant on voit comme
tu vois pas de mandat d les individus de
fleurs jaunes qui sont cons vivent donc
on a encore du feuillage de ceux qui
sont mutilés pour pour quelques-uns
dette
l'histoire de ce sentier continue aussi
avec les noms celui de textor par
exemple qui vient de textor de ravisy un
militaire qui a réalisé le premier la
topographie de la zone et qui agissaient
sous les ordres du gouverneur louis sac
doré semaine gouverneur qui organisait
la colonisation des eaux peu après
l'abolition de l'esclavagé mais surtout
qui serait tombée dans le cratère
visible au début du sentier et qui lui
aurait donné son nom
la boucle est bouclée et notre randonnée
terminée
c'est déjà ce sentier bain au delà de de
la variations d'altitude et de
végétation s'est aussi de l'impression
de redécouvrir le volcan par le sentier
des découvreurs et avery livres
d'histoire voilà que j'invite tout le
monde à découvrir en plus c'est un
itinéraire qui qui nous permet soit de
redescendre sur la plaine des cafres
soit de repas servis le piton de l'eau
et aux deux redescendu à la plaine des
palmistes ou tout simplement de
continuer le sentier des découvreurs en
montant au volcan par le gérant n'a ce
que je n'aime pas sur ce sentier c'est
les usages qui en sont faits on servait
été à plusieurs au bois pour constater
de la mutilation de cette plante dont
principalement le fleur jeunes qui
khiêm utilise pour appeler plus créatif
on dit que c'est de la tradition mais on
sait très bien que nous endettent seront
donc moi j'encourage gens qui me
regardent aujourd'hui n'en jetez plus le
temps d'être comme ça on arrêtait on va
arrêter de détruire nos armes
construite en 1927 et réhabilité dans
les années 90 la villa des tourelles au
coeur du domaine des tourelles est
aujourd'hui un véritable emblème de
l'architecturé de la plaine des
palmistes et notre curiosité de la
semaine
la villa des tourelles elle est
l'emblème de ce qu'on appelle le
changement d'air à la plaine des
palmistes 7 cette maison donc a été
construite par monsieur de villeneuve au
début des années trente à cette époque
les riches propriétaires terriens de la
côte nord-est jusque même sainte-rose
venait à la plaine-des-palmistes un
changement d'ère prendre le frais
ces maisons là vont un petit peu affiché
tout le faz de l'architecturé les
vitrages ans en petit bois les les
façades tout
les détails de l'architecturé
néoclassique tout ce qu'on aperçoit de
l'architecturé hall se situe en façade
et sur cette façade on aura différents
éléments qui vont témoigner d'un certain
niveau social cette maison elle est
vraiment représentatif de l'histoire de
la plaine des palmistes où on a connu
des moments très face des moments un
petit peu plus difficile
oh